two
two three
three
four
check one hey y'all
check two
check three
test four
test five check six checks seven
testing eight testing nine hey Raymond
eleven
you're on it all right
yeah
testing
[Music]
foreign
like on stage tonight this this is
exciting I'm like a part of the worship
team yay for me
welcome to the table happy Sunday what a
beautiful weather day we're having I
loved it I hope you all enjoyed sometime
outside we did putting up Christmas
lights it didn't go well but we can we
don't have to talk about that tonight
um it is the first Sunday of the month
which is exciting because right after
service if you would like to join us at
hat Creek Burger Company it's really
close to here the first Sunday of the
month we like to go and have dinner
together there's an outdoor kids
playground so
all are welcome and there really is like
a space for kids to play you just sit
and talk and actually have adult
conversation without being interrupted
so it's great our Christmas Eve service
which is Christmas Eve will be here at 4
30 Pleasant Valley the church who is
building this is will be meeting at
seven o'clock so we're meeting right
before them to have Christmas carols a
candle lighting and a short sermon which
is also kid-friendly so bring your kids
bring your friends bring your family
bring friends who don't have a church
home and would benefit from just getting
to
bring in Christmas cheer on Christmas
Eve
um okay as we enter into this time of
worship and praise and just being
together as we enter into a next week
um just go ahead and close your eyes
and I wanted just to kind of pray
through some of the lyrics of the first
song that we'll be singing Because
these lyrics are so powerful so as I'm
saying them I invite you to really take
the time to paint the picture in your
heart and in your mind of what these
lyrics are saying because it's really a
powerful image and the image that God
gives to us through his son through his
love through our community
um God you turn Graves into Gardens
God you turn dry bones into armies of
living breathing hope
God you turn seas that cannot be crossed
into highways that can take us from here
to there to where you are
to know you to love you
and I pray that as we enter into this
time of worship and togetherness that we
would see these truths
um in our mind in our heart that the
picture painted stirs us to love deeper
to seek your face to know your face to
hear your voice to know your voice
I pray that we would bond together just
by being in the same room with each
other and with your spirit and that we
would walk out of here feeling not alone
but bonded together and to feel the hug
of one another and the hug of you and
the love of you through our interactions
through a smile through the sermon
through the worship maybe just through
eye contact that lets us know we are
loved we are known we are cherished
because of a god
who created us in his beautiful image
in Jesus name
amen
thanks Kelly if you guys would stand
with us we're going to get started
on our worship and I just wanted to take
a second to point out Eden's first week
up here singing with us so if you guys
could make him feel very loved and
welcome and sing out loud I know
sometimes the very first time you're up
in a new setting singing even if you've
performed other places it can just be so
intimidating so you guys lift your
voices with us sing out and I hope that
this space is one where you feel like
you can bring all of who you are and
invite God into that space with us and
ask him what he has on his heart for you
to receive during this time
Jessie's going to get us started with
Graves into Gardens
[Music]
but it couldn't fill me
a man's empty praise Treasures the Fate
I'll never know
then you came along
[Music]
and put me back together
in every desire now satisfied
Here In Your Love seeing there's nothing
no there's nothing
better than you is nothing
better than you there's nothing
nothing is better than you
I'm not afraid
[Music]
to show you my weakness
my failures Applause Lord you've seen
them all you still call me
friend
cause the god of the man
mountains
is
the god of the valley
and there's not a place your mercy and
Grace will finally
oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
nothing is better than you
I know there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
better than you Lord there's nothing
[Music]
is better than you
dancing
you give Beauty for Ashes
you turn shame into Glory you're the
only one who cares
[Music]
you turn bones into armies
you turn season to highways you're the
only one who cares
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
nothing is better than you
I know there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
is better than you
Grace
you took place
to turn bones into armies
[Music]
into highways you're the only one who
cares
[Music]
no there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
is better than you
all right kids you guys are dismissed to
go to your classes and this week is a
little different we're gonna open up
this classroom over here for our
preschoolers so if you are three years
through first grade you'll go right here
into this store and if you are a big kid
you'll go up through this door up here
thank you so much to our kids ministry
workers who serve these kids week after
week we are so grateful for you yes you
all are amazing
[Applause]
and um now we're going to move into the
prayers of the people if you're joining
us online please leave your comments um
your prayers in the comments sorry and
we will read those aloud and share those
with everyone here in the room we're
grateful for those of you who are with
us not just here in the room but
um but continue to connect with us
online as well
let's pray this out loud together
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
[Music]
thank you
from online Rachel and her health needs
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
there's a Grace when the Heart Is Under
Fire
[Music]
another way when the walls are closing
in
[Music]
and when I look at the space between
where I used to be
I know I will never be alone
there was another in the fire
standing next to me there was another in
the waters
holding him back the Seas should I ever
need reminding
of how I've been set free
where another died for me it's another
in the fire
[Music]
foreign
ers
[Music]
should I fall in the space between what
remains of me and this Reckoning
[Music]
there was another in the fire
standing next to me is another in the
waters
holding back the Seas should I ever need
reminding
of the power that Set Me Free
there's a grave that holds nobody
and that power lives in me there's
another in the fire
oh
there's another in the fire
I can see the light in the darkness as
the darkness bows to him I can hear the
roar in the heavens
[Music]
as the Prison Walls gave in nothing
stands between us nothing stands between
us
foreign
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is Jesus
he wasn't still this and will be through
it all
so come with me in the space between all
the things I'm seeing and this Reckoning
I know I will never be alone
standing next to me you'll be another in
the waters
holding back the sea should I ever need
with my name
to me I'll count the joy come every
battle cause I know that's where you'll
be and I could see the light
[Music]
nothing stands between us nothing stands
between
us nothing stands between us nothing
stands between us
[Music]
there'll be another in the fire
standing next to me don't be another in
the waters
holding back the Seas and should I ever
need reminded
how good you've been to me I'll count
the joy come every battle cause I know
that's where you'll be
count the joy come every battle
[Music]
I can't The Joy come every
never know that's where you
[Music]
just feel like some of us are
maybe going through some battles that
would be very hard to say we're finding
joy in
but I just encourage you tonight
whatever it is that's your battle
would you trust that God has something
for us in the middle of it
that God is doing a good work in you
that he's on your side he's with you in
it
and sometimes what Joy looks like is US
knowing that we're not alone
us knowing that we're seen and loved
foreign
Jesus would your love continue to
transform us
would we be able to behold the way that
you come and you make all things new
things that seem dead things that seem
to be hopeless
you have a way with your love of
transforming them
foreign
[Music]
Darkness like the deadline You Are My
Redeemer
behold
behold the love can do
behold behold
he's making all things new
behold
behold the love can do behold
behold he's making all things new
we've been struck down we're not
destroyed
we've sown in tears
[Music]
tears
my eyes
[Music]
be
he's making all these two
behold
behold the love can do
behold he's making all things
[Music]
come let us
adore him
[Music]
oh come let us
we'll give you all the glory
we'll give you all the
glory will you give you all the glory
[Music]
oh come let us
adore him
oh come let us adore
oh come let us
[Music]
cry
Christ
[Music]
God thank you for who you are
thank you that you're an example of
unconditional love
that you're the one who shows us what
love really is
laying down its life
believing the best
sacrificing on behalf of others making
room and space
for the people on the margins for the
Forgotten and the voiceless
God would we embody that this Christmas
season
would we make space
would we open up our hearts and our
homes
and our families to others who need to
experience love and belonging
and would we find that for ourselves
inside of you
would we behold Your Love
this season
and the way that it changes us the way
that it meets us where we're at
pulls us forward
in your name I pray
amen
do you guys greet the people around you
and then you can be seated and Brett
will get us started on the message
well good evening
Grace and peace it is so good to be with
you all and uh as always that includes
those of you joining us online
we see you
we love you lots and uh and anyone here
who is um new thank you so much for um
for being with us so uh let's see we are
in the midst of a series right now
um titled Advent at the table and uh
Advent of course this is like a kind of
a season in the church calendar that
isn't a celebration of Christmas per se
it's really like the whole um kind of
season of preparation for Christmas so
it's kind of the the sense of longing
and um
awaiting for the arrival of God in the
world so the word Advent it comes from
the Latin adventus which means arrival
and so Advent tends to be a time where
we talk um not only about Christ but a
lot about like either
um his first arrival in uh at Christmas
or his ongoing arrival via the presence
of the Holy Spirit and how Christ is
like present to us even here and now in
day-to-day life and then as we talked a
lot about last week um like God's full
arrival
um or christful arrival at the end of
all things when God is all in all and uh
love saturates this world and all
creation and uh so that's kind of what
the season of advent is all about so
um
I hope is everyone up to date on their
Christmas shopping
everyone y'all on it
just I just need to make sure it's just
a reminder it's coming quicker than you
think I haven't started
okay I have I've been thinking seriously
about it and jotting down ideas in this
is how we jot now jotting down ideas
means with your thumbs on a phone you
know not a pencil I haven't seen a
pencil in three years
um so okay just just a quick reminder
all right so our uh the title of our
message tonight is uh knowing god
knowing self uh knowing others and um
our reading this week
um is from the book of Isaiah chapter 11
verse 1 through 4 and there's probably
many other thousands of churches reading
this because it's part of the the whole
church calendar and some of the
prescribed readings for the Advent
season and um before we read it I want
to name that um this is this passage is
speaking prophetically
um about Christ it was actually written
hundreds of years before he was born but
of course Christians as we went back and
kind of reread the Old Testament
um saw passages that very clearly seem
to um point to who Christ would be uh
and so it is very poetic so you'll
notice
um it mentions like this uh the the name
Jesse and Jesse just for reference is
the father of the famous King David
who's probably the most beloved uh King
in all of Israelite history and he's of
course he's like the uh you know sling
in the stone taking down Goliath that
David uh and uh so so it didn't write
and then Jesus comes from that kind of
family line so that's what it's if you
don't have that background honestly this
opening is just completely weird
sounding so uh Isaiah chapter 11 verses
one through four it says a shoot
will come up from the stump of Jesse you
can hear how poetic and you know
metaphorical it is
from his roots a branch will bear fruit
the spirit of the Lord will rest on him
that is now speaking of Christ
the spirit of wisdom and of
understanding the spirit of counsel and
of Might the spirit of the knowledge and
fear of the Lord
and he will Delight in the fear of the
Lord he will not judge by what he sees
with his eyes or decide by what he hears
with his ears but with righteousness he
will judge the needy with Justice he
will give decisions for the poor of the
Earth
so I think uh arguably one of the most
misunderstood phrases in all of
scripture is is this line that's
repeated In this passage about the fear
of the Lord I don't know if maybe you
had thoughts running through your head
as I read it you know it just it doesn't
sound like a very happy you know I mean
like the key to everything is the fear
of the Lord and
um yeah it is there's some kind of uh I
think just our mind gets going you know
in different directions I think
well here's the strange thing is I went
back I just read like dozens of that
phrase and like how it comes up in
scripture and how it's used and what's
so strange about it is over and over and
over
um it the the passage that mentions it
it's always so uh positive
and at times downright
um kind of happy which is somewhat
ironic sounding you know I mean it's
like the fear of the Lord is great you
know and it's just like whoa what uh and
I think this is where
um like what we might expect is you know
a passage like the fear of the Lord
shall come upon you and you shall weep
for your many sins and but that's like
the Bible just never says it like that
so here's like a few examples this is
just kind of from all over we've got
like a famous one from Proverbs one from
first Samuel and then a passage from
Acts and uh just quick verses so it says
from Proverbs 1 7 the fear of the Lord
is the beginning of wisdom that's that
if you've ever read The Book of Proverbs
that comes up like over and over and
over uh or first Samuel
if you fear the lord and serve and Obey
him and do not rebel against his
commands and if both you and the king
who Reigns over you follow the lord your
God
good and then exclamation mark just
emphasis on good like oh it's such
goodness and wonderful uh then we've got
acts 9 and then the church throughout
Judea Galilee and Samaria enjoyed a time
of peace and was strengthened living in
the fear of the Lord and encouraged by
the Holy Spirit it increased in numbers
so can you hear there like all these
words you know wisdom good encouragement
like it's just it's so positive but that
of course contrasts with what we are
hearing right so they're just things
there's just like some sort of
Disconnect between
um I think the biblical writers what
they're naming and what we as you know
modern folks are kind of hearing and
interpreting so I think some of where
the disconnects happening is uh in the
original language so the the Hebrew
that's being used at least in the Old
Testament passages uh is the Hebrew
phrase it's two words
Yahweh Yahweh now Yahweh is of course it
just means like Lord or the Lord so it's
the the Lord part of fear of the Lord so
the key word there is yurat
and you're right it's kind of an
interesting word because it's a it's a
feeling word you know people often say
like uh you know I want my translation
of the Bible I just want it literal I
just want a literal translation you know
I don't want those those translators
messing up the original and so here's if
they were to just do like the original
yurat means a flowing of the gut
that is like can you imagine you're like
and a flowing of the gut of the of the
Lord it just sounds like what I mean you
can see where culturally right you gotta
you gotta translate like translation is
interpretation and it's like it's a
little complicated so you say what is
the flowing of it this sounds like oh
gosh this is like a real problem well
it's just what it's really describing is
um if you think of emotions where we
tend to feel them is in the core right
and so this can mean a few things like
yurat not Yahweh but just you're not
isolated
um is often translated as fear because
it can refer to the kind of that stomach
dropping feeling
you know like you're on a roller coaster
get over that it's always that
terrifying kind of click click click
click click click click you know I mean
and they intentionally you know they're
playing it up psychologically they're
messing with you you know click click
click click slow oh slowing slowly and
then oh my God and that's that's the
feeling
you're rocked right there she's like oh
my gosh some of you if you're a little
queasy
maybe I hope no one's actually lost on
the roller coaster but you know it can
happen right so edits that's kind of at
its most intense it can be like that
stomach dropping feeling but also at its
most gentle urot
um is used to really describe like
butterflies in the stomach uh you know
which is not necessary like that would
be um
well which is why that this word you're
right sometimes is translated as like
fear other times in scripture though
it's translated as um all
or reverence
uh or worship and again though it's a
feeling word so it's really describing
the sensation of what it is to have a
sense of awe and reverence and worship
um in other words what I'm kind of
driving at here is that Yahweh this this
famous phrase the fear of the Lord
is it has um it's spoken of in such
glowing terms in scripture because it is
it's not trying to describe so much a
cringing Terror of a violent deity right
but rather a it's a deep and profound
um awe of the one who is beautiful and
good beyond all comprehension
like the fear of the Lord it's it's
movement in our core it's butterflies
dancing it's describing those moments
when we are overwhelmed by Glory when we
are crushed in the best of ways by the
sacred when we are undone by Beauty
there's the famous Pastor really now
turned podcaster Rob Bell he uh some of
you know his name he left his Pastor in
snowy Grand Rapids Michigan and uh moved
out to Southern California and he's I
guess living his dream there where it's
warmer in one of his um he tells the
story because one of his
um habits now like daily routine things
is he tries to always get in the ocean
likes to Surf and other times he paddle
boards
and like stand up something I guess sup
something something like that stand up
paddle board right and so he goes out
there but he told the story of one day
uh he's out there on the ocean and
suddenly
got
he just had this feeling that like
something absolutely immense
was like Underneath Him
not like it just a big fish or something
you know kind of like oh big there's a
dolphin but like no no like something
gigantic
and he said suddenly like he froze
and then he could see like skin
kind of moving
and right next to him he said it's
surfaced it was a blue whale
and there he stood
on his little paddle board
with a 300 foot long it's a football
field
on his battle boys
he said all of a sudden he realized like
Not only was his mouth just hanging open
he said he suddenly realized that he was
crying
but not from Terror
right like oh my it's gonna eat me no no
what was it oh
reference
Wonder
at the beauty in the Majesty
of God
Iraq Yahweh the fear of the Lord have
you ever had a moment like that
right it's it's almost like these um
these moments where where like creation
or some aspect of it whether it's
um like a mountain
or maybe a a snowy quiet Forest
or the eye of someone that you know that
you know that you know adores you
or the laughter of a child
it's suddenly it becomes um not an idol
where you worship it right but an icon
it's like a portal right to the Divine
Right Where suddenly it's it's like
you're just you're overcome
by a sense of awe and wonder at who God
is like that's it
Yahweh it's the fear of the Lord and
this is why um the Bible talks of it in
again such glowing terms because it's
not about like God's gonna get me oh
good that's the beginning of wisdom
right there you're like no no it's it's
standing on that little paddle board and
realizing something immense is around
you right it's that sense of awe and
wonder and Majesty it's been overcome by
God's glory like that's the beauty like
that's that's what the Bible
um is really driving at and
um and for us of course this happens you
know in moments maybe for some of you a
few times in your life maybe we've got a
few Mystics Among Us
once a month I don't know
um but you know what's interesting is
this passage says that that Jesus as
God's son he he lived with that sense
of the one he called father
like every day of his life let's read it
again verse two the spirit of the
knowledge and fear of the Lord
and he will Delight in the fear of the
Lord not remarkable and can you get it
now why he would Delight in that because
not about Terror ah you know no it's you
Delight
in that awe of God
what we might say is this a loving awe
of God it orients me rightly to God
like that's the the proper
um relational Dynamic it's a loving awe
of God it's butterflies in our stomach
maybe even sometimes stomach dropping
but again not in a terrible way but in a
oh my gosh just like Moses of old who
was said to realize he was on Holy
Ground and he just took off his shoes
and bowed
right that this is this is the thing
it's a it's this is what we need a
loving all of God it orients us rightly
to God and the reason I name this and
the reason I titled the message knowing
god knowing self knowing others
um is because the relationship with God
like this is
um like the primary relationship in our
life as we talk often um about here at
the table like how we image God
uh is absolutely everything
um and and even if we're maybe in a
season of like maybe gone through season
deconstruction or maybe we're even here
tonight and you're like I don't know I
don't know if I really even have faith
God's you know out there you know
whatever
um
still I still think this is this truth
is
um
undeniable or like you can't get away
from it because at the end of the day we
still all operate with certain deep core
beliefs about the nature of like call it
capital r reality
or the universe you know it's
interesting how we have these ways of
talking about God without talking about
God you know it just really becomes
plain with words you know like okay not
God the universe you know nature you
know and but but either we believe that
like reality itself the very basis of
all reality is good and wise and loving
or not right or we say Ultimate Reality
it is cold and hard and harsh right can
you kind of track that and like that
that of course um
like either way ultimately we're like
we're really talking about God uh now
what I'm naming though is what for Jesus
right this loving awe of God this is the
heartbeat of it this is where we need to
come back to this relates us rightly
um to God but it doesn't stop there I
took a class once um called knowing self
knowing god
and
because God is our creator in the source
of Who We Are
there's always a deep connection between
us and God
and thus
the the kind of Journey maybe I'll put
it like this
um the more we come to understand accept
and even love ourselves
the more we discover the one who made us
and knows us and loves us
right in other words there's really no
journey into us
that's not at the same time a journey
into God
and vice versa you can't journey into
God
without coming to learn some things
about yourself it was Saint Augustine
who prayed Lord
um let me know myself let me know you
um but there's also a danger here
because it means that the more distorted
oh and some of you really need to hear
this tonight the more distorted your
relationship with yourself
right in other words the more you're
operating from a place of um maybe
hatred or self-rejection or really harsh
judgment I think most of us are always
Our Own Worst critics
you know I've heard I think it was the
therapist who said you we would we never
let people
talk to us the way we talk to us
you know what I mean like and so the
more distorted and kind of
um maybe dysfunctional that relationship
to ourselves is then what happens with
God
can you see it all of the sudden that
real it's almost like we kind of end up
projecting our own kind of fears
insecurities hatreds and then we're like
yep that's the nature of Ultimate
Reality itself you know what I mean like
well and then again if you've come from
it also the reverse is true maybe if you
come from a tradition perhaps even a
wing of Christianity that has some
really messed up images of God because
if we read the Bible without keeping
Jesus as the heartbeat in center of our
faith and of our image of God then you
can absolutely find some passages that
make God sound like a moral monster I
mean Richard Dawkins is essentially
right here famous atheist for those who
aren't in those loops and like he's like
he has critiques and he's right there's
some passages that are like oh gosh oh
gosh right
um and so what happens like if that if
you have this view this image of God as
like going back to the fear of the Lord
stuff like oh I know that fear of God
stuff is like Terror at the deity you
know then then what happens with your
yourself
can you see where it just gets all
messed up
right so there's there's this deep deep
connection
um one way I might put it is
to say that God and again a loving right
all an orientation to God
um God is the outer edge of the puzzle
known as me
God is the outer edge of the puzzle
known as me we're coming into
um it's holiday season of course so
puzzles
any puzzlers out there a few okay I
wonder there's a correlation between
like introvertedness and puzzles I don't
do you think so I'm sure actually oh my
gosh it is it's like you little Zen
monks you just kind of there just your
Christmas music going like just you know
yeah
um of course anyone who's done puzzles
like you know how to do the puzzle right
like the easiest way to solve the puzzle
I mean unless you're just a psycho and
you're like I'm going for the hard way
you're like no every person knows the
outer edge right like you gotta get the
frame like what am I
where are we going here you know what I
mean it's the outer edge and that's kind
of that's essentially what I'm getting
at is like God is that outer edge
and not just God but like a relationship
our orientation or connection to God
um and when we start to get that right
Yahweh knowing god then what do we find
all of the sudden
um some of the kind of identity crisis
like am I loved am I seen am I known am
I worthy am I good enough am I you know
I mean all those questions that we don't
necessarily say out loud because we're
adults and we're trying to adults you
know but they're kind of running through
the back of our heads like all those
questions begin to um get answered but
the truth of this it just like keeps
unfolding uh because Isaiah he continues
so verse two the spirit of the Lord will
rest on him that is Christ the spirit of
wisdom and of understanding the spirit
of counsel and of Might the spirit of
the knowledge and the fear of the Lord
and He will Delight in the fear of the
Lord and then it says this he will not
judge by what he sees with his eyes or
decide by what he hears with his ears
but with righteousness he will judge the
needy I think it was his naming there
seems to be some inherent connection
between Yahweh knowing god right loving
of God and not only perceiving myself
rightly but doing what
perceiving others
rightly
um
and and not just like
as they well I'll put it this way it's I
think it's because we tend to be very
quick to judge others outwardly
like an indictment of like oh how could
you I mean this is no this is like just
the way of the world right this is
Humanity we see a person and we're on it
you know what I mean like we just
are very quick to judge like oh I know
them like that's a hipster right there
you know or what I don't know whatever
like we just label and we have these
ways of seeing people and determining
and because of this when we become very
um kind of self-conscious about our own
you know I mean I think of us kind of
like peacocks you know with their
feathers and uh we all can have our
feathers you know I mean like just
different feathers for different people
it's like some people it's like cars you
know like that's just feathers you know
it's interesting how cars are
um well almost everything in human like
in culture is like signs and symbols you
ever thought about that like you could
think of a car like no a car is for
transportation
ever like a car it communicates you know
what I mean like it speaks your values
and even if it's like not such a great
car you know like um I used to have a
really bad cars and Nissan Altima was
like 2002. I used to make jokes of it
about it all the time during preaching
it was all the handles were broken but
even that was kind of a you know I mean
it was like a communication like hey I'm
not the kind of guy who needs an awesome
car okay I'm secure maybe you know I
don't know
um you know I mean like everything's
communic clothes jewelry technology I
found watches you know whatever it is
like there's just there's things there's
ways that we communicate like kind of
who we are what we're into and and the
danger of course is that we slip into
relating to each other in that surfacey
way
and and it becomes um
you know I mean it's one thing to like
walk through a city and kind of be
judged in that way or like okay whatever
but man when in like friendships in
church communities in places where you
would hope it would be different when
it's not
that's like the worst isn't it
like and and why is that it's because
well I think it's because Christ is like
modeling a different way when I think of
who Jesus was and how he connected and
related to people
almost like he was well this he wasn't
judging by the outward appearance
how someone presents
their body language their smile or lack
thereof their clothes their status their
place in the social hierarchy it's like
he looked at them and he just saw
straight to the heart like the core of
who they are
and so what's our call like this is who
we're called to be
I was thinking about
uh I'll close with this there's oh
there's every generation has like its
little kids sports movies
and at least when I was growing up in
like the 90s it was um Little Giants
it was a big one oh I love that and uh
Mighty Duck
yes I got into skating just for that I
did well I lived in Texas so I couldn't
ice skate so rollerblading just because
of my index you know and uh before that
I didn't ever see this one maybe it's
just just part of me it was the Bad News
Bears I guess was another one maybe
there's others sorry I have a cut off
point where I lose track of the kids
sports movies but you know it's kind of
interesting that like there's a Trope
with them isn't there like it's like
this formula that they keep playing out
but we love it like and the formula is
you know you start with like the bad
team
you know and there they are like if
they're ice skating they're terrible if
they're playing baseball you know
they're just like I mean just they're
awful they can't tackle they can't run
like none of it right and then who's
like when do things pivot
they find who
like a coach
you know what I mean and the coach looks
at them and it's like
people
I see greatness
you know what I mean and then all the
kids are like
who
oh and he's like you I believe in you
and it's it's funny it's like the
coach's job is then to like call out
what those judging by the surface
appearance like it's there but they
can't see it you know what I mean and
like each person kind of has their role
it doesn't mean they're all awesome at
everything right but it's like the
coach's job is to draw out the greatness
in each of them and when I think of like
a church community and who we're called
to be like that's kind of my image is we
look at people and we're not we're just
not judging like the world judges or
just look to the outward appearance
makes a judgment it's like we begin to
learn to see deeper
we see people like hey just as our
benediction
um which we close with each week right
you are a child of God
and that's when we see people
we see them as children of God deeply
known deeply loved in God's up to
something in their life and our job is
to like see it and call it out and
encourage them
right he won't judge by what he sees
with his eyes or decide by what he hears
with his ears that's our call knowing
god knowing self and then let that
launch us into knowing others so as we
uh come to the table of the Lord tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ in the wine we
do it as an advent people
we do it as a people learning
not to live in a cringing Terror of God
but a loving relationship to God we
learn it as or we engage it as people
taking in Christ connecting with Christ
letting him heal the broken things
inside us and then as a people sent out
of this place to love well so as we come
forward in just a moment I encourage you
to do it with that that heart posture so
we practice um here what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you would like to
participate in taking the bread which
symbolizes the body of Christ the wine
which symbolizes his blood
um that that basically there's no like
theological police whatever you're just
you're free to engage that if there's
something in you that wants to connect
with Christ then you're welcome to do
that and
um
the way we'll kind of do this is we'll
just start at the front and just kind of
work our way back row by row so we don't
get a super long line and then
I think there might be one more thing
but oh yeah uh you can partake whenever
you'd like so right away or if you want
to go to your seat and then take
um just do that at your own um kind of
leading so this is the table
not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
in you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
you would like to please stand with us
we're going to close with this Christmas
Carol
that kind of speaks to receiving the
news of Jesus um Emmanuel God With Us as
something beautiful to behold something
to Rejoice about
um so let's sing this together
foreign
[Music]
Rejoice rejoice
right
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you all for being here tonight
as we close out I wanted to let you know
that right after the service I'll be
standing at the back if there's anything
I can pray for you about or with you or
just give you a big hug I will be back
there to do that if you're a visitor and
you want to get better connected there's
a box right outside this door on the
right where you can fill out some
information and we would love to get to
know you more and help plug you in to
maybe one of our meetup groups or up
here at we're doing worship which you
did awesome by the way well done Round
of Applause
it was beautiful absolutely beautiful
and again Christmas Eve service will be
here at 4 30 right before Pleasant
Valley service right after the service
tonight join us at hat Creek for our
monthly meal would love to see you there
and my husband and I choose to
financially give to the table because we
really do believe that what we're doing
here from the songs that we're singing
to the sermons that are being preached
to the meetup groups that meet online
that we are really building a shelter a
safe place for all people any people
to come and to know Jesus to seek God's
face and to find Refuge here and that
not just for the people in this room but
for the children in that room and the
little children over in that room this
is for them too and so by giving we live
in a world where monetary value carries
these things it matters and so I just
wanted to share that that's why we
choose to give financially and you can
do that online or at the box right
outside the door
um now I'm going to send you guys off
with the benediction that Brett was
talking about so if you will close your
eyes if you want to open your hands as a
posture of receiving this blessing and
prayer for the week ahead of you
um this is for you
you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to determine highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
peace be with you go and have a great
week and may the face of God shine upon
you
see you at hat Creek
[Music]
do it shall come to thee always right
shall come to thee always
[Music]